- Nina's going to freak out.
Where's Nina?
Come on, Nina!
Let's come freak out!
(spirited music)
What's up, believe nation?
Happy weekend, it's Evan,
and we've got, where is he?
Oh, the Hey Man, he's being shy.
We, quick video today.
We've got Teemo, he's
getting his hair cut.
This is what Teemo looked
like before the haircut,
and we just got back from hearing
that his haircut is finished.
We're going to go get Teemo
and see what he looks like!
I said to make it really short.
We'll see how short they made it.
The floor is lava.
I got to get up!
I can't get up!
I got the camera!
(chuckles)
- I'm safe, you died.
- You're safe, I died.
Let's go get Teemo.
I'm also testing out my new, what is this?
Stablizer!
Let me see what, see
how good this video is.
New stabilizer.
(lively music)
Okay, open the door.
Let's get the Teemo.
Pull.
Let's go see him.
Oh, there he is!
There he is!
Teemo, look at you!
Where did all your hair go?
Looking good, mister!
Nina's going to be surprised.
Look at these two guys.
Teemo's haircut cost us $80.
That's an expensive haircut, mister,
but hopefully, Nina likes it, too.
Nina's going to be home
in about half an hour.
We're going to go pick her up,
and she's going to freak out!
Welcome home, mister!
You want pets?
You want a belly rub?
Teemo wants a belly rub.
Isn't he a cute Teemo?
Eat, Teemo, come!
Look, look at his food.
Oh my god, that's the yummiest food ever!
Look at that!
Oh, yeah!
Post-haircut celebration, yum.
The guy's falling asleep.
He was too busy playing
with the other dogs.
Now he got tired.
He's passing out.
(swish)
All right, Nina's on her way.
We're going to pick her
up and show her Mister Mo.
See what she thinks.
She's going to freak out.
How much is Nina going to freak
out on a scale of one to 10?
What do you think?
I'm thinking, I think
it's going pretty high.
I'm thinking it's pretty high.
I'm thinking she's going to freak out.
Look at this guy!
How cute is he?
I would freak out.
We're here waiting for Nina.
Teemo's chilling, Teemo's waiting.
Hello, you're waiting to see Nina?
You're waiting to see
Nina and spaz her out?
Exciting!
Nina's going to freak out,
Nina's going to freak out.
Where's Nina?
Come on, Nina, let's come freak out!
(upbeat music)
There she is, Teemo!
There she is!
Go, go Teemo, go!
Go, Teemo, go, come on, go!
Go, Teemo, go!
- Oh my god!
oh, yes
oh my god!
You got a haircut!
oh my god, oh my god
I can't even recognize him.
You're so tiny!
Oh my goodness!
(inaudible)
Why cause the bandana?
- No because of the short hair.
- Cause the short hair and the bandana.
Oh my god!
When did you go get him a haircut, huh?
- Now
- Now?
Where did you guys go?
- (Evan) What do you think?
- Oh my god, you're so
I can't even recognize you.
- An hour ago
- An hour ago?
Oh my god!
- (Evan) Is the haircut Nina approved?
Oh my god you're so tiny
my goodness, MUAH!
- Alright thank you guys for watching
and hopefully you enjoyed
the Teemo haircut edition
Have a great weekend
Continue to believe and whatever
- Your one word is we'll see you soon
- Much love
(upbeat music)
- (Hey Man) He lost his precious hair
- He lost a lot of hair
That's how I hold Teemo
- (Evan) holds like a baby.
- Yeh
- (Inaudible)
(swoosh)